[Music]
hi I'm Mike Martin the lead designer for
dirt 5 you join us and the challenging
race from one of our stunning Norway
circuits of a beautiful sunny day how's
the race unfolds I'm going to talk a
little about dirt 5s career mode
Parker mode spans over 130 events across
a trace types and five chapters and
covers a wide variety of locations from
Norway as shown here to China a Morocco
Vai Brasil with many more stunning stops
along the way we've gotten to great
lengths to provide players with the
choice to complete the events they want
to in the order they choose so the
career structure we've set up branches
often meaning players get to focus on
completing the disciplines they want in
order to progress
when it comes to progression there's
cash to buy cars and stamps that unlock
different chapter finales both the one
by completing them placing well in the
races in addition to that we've added
layers over the race to race action with
longer term goals provided by sponsors
players must pick a sponsor to race for
each offers the players both race and
career objectives to complete to gain
rap with them
gained an offer up and level off with a
particular sponsor and player wins
rewards such as larger payouts
customization are sets for a delivery
editor or even full-blown bespoke
liveries creates by real livery artists
death spray customs or shaunb all
players can pick from 20 real-world
sponsors including motorsport favorites
such as Goodyear or sparker - big brand
heavyweights like Monster Energy or
Pepsi
guarding players through the career is
our stellar cast of players we've got AJ
your mentor and current top dog at the
dirt series played by Troy Baker of last
of all Spain playing off against Nathan
Drake himself Mel the north's carrots at
Bruno Durand and often coming superstar
who's exploded on the scene in the dirt
series winning races left right and
center and gunning for AJ's crowd AJC's
potential for the player who wants to
train and nurture them to be the next
big thing in off-road racing finally
acting as MCS to this guiding our
players through the campaign the u.s.
car culture Giants go not media James
Pomfrey and Nolan Sykes run the dirt
podcasts the actors tutorials prevents
introductions and they move the story
forward in their own unique style
podcasters aren't alone though they have
special guest stars including Bruno and
AJ along with more stars from the
motorsport and driving culture worlds
such as Jaime Chadwick and slap Trek
we're really proud of how dirt fives
career is coming along and can't wait
for you to play it when the game hits
the shelves keep watching out for more
updates and news in the coming months
we've got plenty more surprises for you
[Music]